oh welcome back gamers
no i hate myself i wanted to join i'm
like no i can't
intro completed welcome back wow we
traveled so
far what are we doing we are
i climb mountain now oh climbing very
epic
i'm gonna go up here and see what the
hell is up here heck
hey sorry thank you swore now i have to
fight you on top of mountain
to show susan i am not actually bad
susan look i play minecraft now i'm nice
she's like i give you good ads don't
worry she's like i put you on trending
please play every day alpaca
i'll get the left one are those wild
alpacas they're wild
epically
i want one we don't have any saddles
where we can ask them from are you
spitting like the alpacas
okay how about this we put them in a
hole so we can just grab them later
okay i think this one likes me
horrible okay go in the hole no stop
climbing is yours in the hole yet bro
no i'm oh i hit one oh my mine is in the
hole ah there's nobody they're spitting
on you jack
i'm sorry don't you get one thing on
jack he's
innocent i don't have a shovel did you
put one in the hole
yeah of course oh oh you're on you're on
this now that's easier
yes stay in the hole stay in the hole
you don't need a dad wear your new puppy
hey sorry
we are oh come on my god fast enough for
digging use your tiny hands
why he's too fast he can't be stopped
there we go here we go push him in push
him in quick
oh my god you pushed him out i did not
i did not i think they will despawn just
so we're clear
that no no this is going to work perfect
stay in hole we'll find you guys it's
because we care
i put a lid just to make sure he's safe
okay and i give sacrifice
to watershed no to golden alpaca
my inventory is full it's a mesh really
i have like five things
oh can i give you some yeah please
here's a gold nugget
would you get all this sweet seeds red
stone
if you have like food that would be
great awesome
who's so cool with you everybody's so
sick all right i have food
and god lord you're like at mcdonald's
i'll take it mcdonald's have mutton
apparently oh dude i want a pet dolphin
in my game
yeah me too why can't you not bullcrap i
don't know
i i trapped one before and he got me
flower biome
no special no never mind it's not it's
regular
because i have a flower island in my
game is that special
am i special yeah yeah you're special oh
my god
did we just emigrate to a new world
because i feel like that's what we did
even though it's equally bad pretty much
we left scandinavia we need new accents
um i killed you with diamond pickaxe we
went to riyadh
it is very epic
oh my god kill skeleton skeleton too
scary
skeleton to bone everyone my family
because we don't feed
okay no go back it's way worse f go back
sheep sheep sheep wait why is there a
long string in this guy
what is that oh it hasn't loaded yet wow
look at that epic mountain
it looked really cool dude i don't like
this do you like this
no i don't like anything of what we're
doing we're not doing
anything i'm trying to figure out oh
let's go to spruce
place i like the spruce place we could
have had like seven
story house by now which killed the
witch
oh help me please to put a spell on you
i don't even know who you are
please help i'm about to die
oh i heard that please help i'm coming
please help
my sword went out all i have is a
pickaxe i have an axe
i'm gonna die i'm gonna die no i'm dead
i'm gonna die i'm serious you're not i
have one health you're not gonna die the
witch is dead
we need to sleep otherwise we won't
respawn sleep
sleep oh my god you have arrows
everywhere oh my god i'm about to die
i saved you though you did bro thanks
bro no problem bro three hours too
late cringe three hours later
okay oh god there's creepers everywhere
um okay well i don't i don't should we
go back
what do we do i don't know keep pushing
forward okay let's go to the spruce
okay i'm there i have diamond pickaxe i
really don't want to lose this
we have to kill sheep if you see oh we
need to sleep jack we need to sleep
i i know but we need to work oh there's
a village here we can sleep in the
village hurry follow me
sweet oh god wait there's water fees
tiny doggos okay watch out for berries
they hurt
they sting they sting like tears from
your eyes oh my god you have special
technique of jumping i didn't know that
makes you go faster oh my god
noob ah
okay okay oh god wait where the hell do
i respond
i told you bro we were supposed to sleep
you died outside oh no
i'm in the original place
wait i have to sleep i have to sleep
otherwise bad
wait do we have to sleep at the same
time three two one sleep there's no beds
oh i'm sleeping that's not bad i'm
sleeping
oh a fun time i can't sleep wait wait
wait
this whole series is me dying
diamond bruh three diamonds cool cold
not asleep okay one second that's
awesome sleep is so happy for you
oh there's no there's a freaking black
banter
bro you're missing out bro okay wait i
i will sleep in that i will dream of you
and maybe that will make you teleport
what do you think teleport to you can i
just do it if i if i sleep
okay i'm sleeping i'm dreaming of jack
dream of jack
dream of green oceans oh look good
morning
top of morning top of mine okay minus
727.
don't do me like this minus
2 000. i'll i'll make a boat
are you actually gonna walk no i'm gonna
sail
i'm walking all of this i respect i
respect this don't i do need stop dying
though
i'm gonna make bread ow i i can't make
bread
i think this is a cool place i like this
place yeah
it's awesome yeah it's so cool i mean i
can come back if you want
jack you're not gonna believe what i
just found what not one
not two seven hundred potatoes
oh my god it was so worth it this is why
i made the sacrifice
um that's why i thought we could
emigrate to a new planet
just like elon musk let's go to a new
planet yeah
mars he's like hey mars hello hello mars
it is me hello it's me elon musk hello
elon music okay wait what's your
coordinates
oh i see okay minus 729
it's not that far no no it isn't i've
gone further
maybe i'll just go through the nether
and die in lava five times again
oh my god see it's funny because i can
joke about it now
now that it hasn't happened i i did the
exact same thing in my own playthrough
again
whoa there's armor racks i went into the
nether and forgot
sorry tell me i went into the nether and
forgot flint and steel so i had to use a
gas to no
and then he disrupted the lava and i
died in it oh my god
i have a problem jack you keep dying
i know i'm horrible you're gonna love
this i built like one two three four
five
six houses wow yeah it's crazy built or
stole
uh does it matter stealing them is
better
okay stone i stole it oh awesome
i love stealing people's houses jumping
in stealing all their stuff sleeping in
their beds
i like how i was so amazed by our place
the first time
and then it's like oh but there's
nothing else in here
i like the spruce area though it reminds
me of the for fjords
the fjords back in bjorn yeah bjork
they say they say you bjork enough time
you become a better
to say once you bjork you never go yeah
bjerk
the way you speak jack the words remind
you of the motherland
reminds me of my mother oh that's nice
my mother's land i'll make sure that if
i ever meet her i'll talk like this to
her
oh hello hello do you understand
felix miyam felix miyama
okay oh so good to meet you
hey big bouncy baby
you'll meet her on the wedding all right
i'm gonna do that
i'm gonna give a speech and even if
you're trying to
speech speech hello swedish i speak like
this
so you understand me oh what a sheep
watershed
i don't even know what half of the stuff
from your series is
no i don't watch the episodes i just
keep getting secondhand knowledge from
everybody
it's literally just uh what is she i it
still doesn't explain anything
you say that like it's a normal thing in
the game what do you mean she's a sheep
in the water don't make me talk about it
it's too painful
okay i get it sorry you lose enough
water sheeps
i break any man i'm not scared of no man
but that water sheep
it frightens me that's me okay i'm at
700 700.
damn bro minus 2 000 minus 700.
oh yeah minus minus i love this area we
should fence this
uh city so we can protect and sleep that
is what vikings did
this is what we do we take their hot
babes oh my god we can go across
the water babes here steal their house
that's why
all scandinavians so attractive we
picked out all the good ones
does that mean we become prettier and
prettier as a species
but then why you ugly oh my god oh my
god
i can't believe you can't believe he
just said that to me
what if i find something like totally
epic and i come to you
and we make epic if we find a horse
that we tame they we can give them both
armor because i have two iron
armors for horse for horse yes for horse
[Applause]
wait that's not the armor you were going
to give me is it because you think i'm a
horse
i'm trying to make the potatoes into a
heart but it looks like fork
but understand what i'm trying to do
well i'll get it
don't ruin surprise every time an
irishman looks at a potato it looks like
a heart
yeah i i can see that i like how at the
start of each episode i complained that
we don't get enough done and then i die
and i just spent the whole episode
trying to get back i don't know
okay it's okay don't cry
i kill cow now sorry cow hungry
i thought you were vegan oh they are
vegan cows
oh good you don't know vegan cats is
this another thing like water sheep
no i shouldn't i should never have
brought up water sheep
what you talking about water sheep you
never go back you never forget the pain
there's a bunch of sheep around me
though that i can kill for vegan beds
i kind of need the meat as well see why
progress in minecraft when you can just
steal other people's progress
i make bed and i sleep make bed and
sleep
oh good night world okay good night good
night sleep sleep i sure hope
green boy is thinking about me always
where is he it's almost like he's
speaking in my brain
but why he had to die i mean
masaka
oh he's close i smell potato
is you it's me it's my deodorant oh my
god i see him
okay i give you a gift oh thank you
anthony
for me iron chest plate yeah for you and
follow me
goody bag you can take
hard potato hard potato
and also look soft potatoes i know you
like salt potatoes
you're a good friend diamond pickaxe
for me yeah i don't know how many times
i got it for you now
it's the gift that keeps on giving the
gift i keep on giving this video is just
massive like
look it goes all the way even up here
jeepers what should we call the village
they all have eye patches i know they're
like blacksmiths
kitty so cute i think we're in a pirate
village
pirate blacksmiths the viking village
pirate viking
why am i not eating the bread that you
gave me i'm telling you man my brain
just turns off
just as long as my minecraft pickaxe is
okay
this diamond pickaxe is going to go on
forever that's really part of our
problem right now we really need to like
tame
a wolf we need our dogs there's foxes
here
but we need a leash for them though so
sad you can still breed them
oh no they have a baby already they're
two babies make them more baby
oh wait they need to mate with someone
else yeah that's just a mom with two
babies
oh dummy mo oh look he's with us now oh
if only we had a a leash we had two
leads we could have two foxes now oh my
god that'd be so cool
maybe we could uh build house build a
mansion
right in the middle of all their houses
yeah on top of all the bears
yeah wait which is who has the biggest
house and we'll build a house on top of
it
it's like a two-story house back here i
haven't built anything in a while i'm
down
this one seems good i'll get some wood
at least now you don't have to worry
about dying as well
i always worry about dying in this game
wait there's no lava around is there
how about we just use this house right
in the middle
steal someone else's house yeah just
build on top of it i like your thinking
these are gonna have to go though i'm
not a fan you don't like those
now it looks like our house in the
middle of the shop
shop shop okay i'm doing some
renovations because
it has mossy blocks all over we need to
do up the house a little bit
i agree i agree maybe we can add a floor
to it
what's going on over here you guys
having a disco
top of morning tougher morning disco
hello
what happens when you ring the bell why
do they all run away if creatures attack
you can ring it and they all go into
their house
oh my god they called they went to our
house
uh excuse me okay everyone in the same
building am i gonna have to commit a
murder
don't do it jack i know it's tempting
but you've been free of murder he has a
sweeping edge iron sword
for 11 emeralds how many emeralds do you
have four
this is so sad but you have six soft
potatoes for one
whoa
of arthropods it's for against spiders
instead
bane of arthropods ii and knocked back
one for 16 emeralds
yeah i never traded with those type of
villagers
hello hey hey hoarding iron nuggets up
here bro
hello do you know see me i i do okay
oh these blocks are not going to do they
have moss all over them how did you guys
live here with mold disgusting
it was one of yours yeah we definitely
improved this place
absolutely you're welcome so much we
should build it
hey watch this
[Laughter]
we should probably sleep actually okay i
got this one there's one downstairs go
okay go all i see is i'm here massacre
yeah
guys get out of my house jack i don't
know how to tell you this
i'm making my own house what
your house look like an old lady
i want my i want our house come on let's
be lord together
i don't want to steal other people's
house we can be the mayors of this town
that's true and then they'll have to
listen to us we ring the bell every
morning
we top of the morning to them how about
we make like a reverse tower so it's
skinny on the bottom but gigantic on the
top
like my peepee it just starts at one
block
oh see now the good idea come then
then two by two or uh yeah yeah
i ran out of bricks
[Laughter]
maybe we should go in the mines then
there's a mine down here
where's the mine here perfect oh oh oh
golem hey bro you want to help oh my god
trying not to hit you nice oh my god
sometimes the mobs lag and then they
just attack you even though oh sorry
yeah
that's okay bro i just hear an enderman
possible
in minecraft enderman in minecraft i was
so shocked the first time i saw one and
then it's like oh
they're everywhere yeah i had no idea
what it was yeah
shut up dudes do some work build a house
for us
that'd be cool if you could employ them
be like hey guitar
yes but we're not under contract we have
no union to protect ourselves
we have to unionize quickly and do it
quick boy
you can't play first place all of a
sudden
maybe the diamond pickaxe is like your
um thing like voldemort like your
attachment
to life my horcrux your horcrux yeah
that's it why you haven't died yet
because every time you manage to throw
your diamond pickaxe somewhere
last second so what are you doing in
your minecraft right now
uh i redid my entire castle oh it looks
awesome it has a giant irish flag on top
oh you finally got it nice
i got a girlfriend for my dog oh me too
bro
except boyfriend oh that's pretty nice
what's his name
sven's boyfriend so original
give him a name bro he's nice person's
boyfriend's
feelings yeah yeah yeah why it's such a
bad
month for pets on youtube they'll get a
comeback through minecraft
oh oh i like that
did you hear that yeah what did you do i
was building stairs to get in and out of
this hole
and a creeper came up behind me oh my
god i got a few mounts if you want to
start building
your mats it just sounded like fortnite
all of a sudden again
oh is that a fortnite thing yeah dude
i'm out of mats oh let's see
whoa you make excellent entrance
entrance to
cave thing wow completion look at this
i can fit a whole bus full of children
down here that's the plan
bus full of children go down the hall
there's a cover up these halls as well
we take their taxes and we put it back
into city we make it good
look everyone we give a nice place we
give back to people
i found bed before anybody else who's
mine it's mine dibs
they're all like i don't know
it just sounds like squidward i feel
like they just looked at squidward
and we're like yeah that's that's us you
know spongebob is in the game right
have you done an ocean temple yet no
then you'll see spongebob
well they did make a character based on
slenderman and just called him enderman
challenge that's good enough
good job
[Laughter]
dude me and fire do not cooperate
should we do it like this where we build
only in the edge out and not like
yeah so it's like a reverse pyramid
almost yeah oh dude that's sick
did you just be like this guy
would you just be like nanny how do we
get on it
uh we're gonna have to build some like
mega stairs going into the front of it
ooh so how about we like leading from
this pathway
we have stairs oh it's kind of hold out
hold up one thing yeah but we can we can
change we can make it more centered we
center this and then we have like
badass like imperial steps going all the
way inside of it
yes and then we hollow out some of the
middle of it and then go up into the
middle
and inside we'll have a bunch of parrots
in a jukebox and there will be a party
yeah took a little long there
dude you don't like this idea i don't i
i was on board man i just didn't fully
grasp
the full concept of it at first yeah
i might i got blue screen again from
playing minecraft this is the fourth
time
we could make a a piston door we can
keep the symmetrical shape of the
place but we can still have an entrance
coming from the bottom oh
yeah i like that this became our new
mine i like that
built this whole entrance thing this is
just for now this is just to
steal rock i see the other one is
ceremonial
we borrow from earth oh my god
eat them until it's too late
so what if we burn down the village
build our house the only thing that will
be just to be a temple of fire
it'll spit out flames we brought fire to
your village
i'm just happy that we're doing
something that doesn't involve you dying
that just doesn't involve us talking in
a swedish accent for an
hour i remember back in the day when i
did like
the montages right yeah when i was
trying and create those moment as much
as possible like always always having
that in mind
just because oh yeah yeah you got it
okay if i exaggerate a little extra head
then perfect for the montage
later when uh we completed everyone be
like how you built that you must have
used creative
my meatball i wonder if people say that
about my castle i was even saying as
well
like oh i built it using creative i mean
survival
because i tripped myself up thinking
about creating so much
but everyone's gonna be like he did it
he said it
exposed drop alert i want to see this
from our other spawn
i want to be able to see it from space
chinese wall and upside down pyramid
i think they're having a party by the
fjord yeah that's what they were doing
last time okay break it up you guys
break it up go home actually work for
disco bullish
dutch people in a party 2019.
doesn't their outfits look like
dutchman's
i guess so wait if i mix up dutch
and uh where's the sound of music
recording
austria that's very different it's the
same country it's gonna say maybe we
should take out the block at the very
bottom so it's a floating pyramid
oh let's see hey you're holding up the
pyramid
ah oh my god
it's on top of my head jack big brain
this is the house for my brain
that's awesome how do you get in now
it's how you enter maybe you can build a
water elevator underneath it
see that's what i wanted you to do now
it looks like it has a pooping
pooping pyramid no it's gone now all
right no more of it
speak no more of this and then when it's
done we steal the bell and we put it on
top of our
ah that's sick so that we can disperse
and then we snipe all the villagers
what are you going to keep seeing
pictures of you with peepee poopoo
written all over
i feel like i don't even need to watch
your series at this point
everyone else will just give me all the
information that's all you need to know
was he a good was he a good pig he was
his best boy he said like he died in the
with the fight
no not really either die pp or you die
poop
no either die irrelevant or live long
enough to play minecraft
oh i can't help it if minecraft
is legitimately fun i've recorded
minecraft today and then we're recording
now and then later i'm gonna livestream
minecraft
you gotta do it man you gotta do it i'm
getting cobblestone
are you lost old man i think he's c9
come on follow me
is he down there he's down here but
don't worry i save you it's too dark i
can't you can barely see him
get out of there just get out where's
the entrance
if you're not out in 10 seconds i kill
three
tour swore
it's always that thing you never know
what you're going to build in minecraft
and then suddenly
genius stroke of genius i think i have
one of your axes by the way i just
realized
so good man sure he's caring sharing is
caring and
building is the best part of minecraft
oh yeah dude this looks sick bro
haha surprise second stack
who are you surprising myself okay hey
has it been windy for you in brighton
yeah yeah it's wild i i i got
those like rent-a-bike things uh-huh and
i went to the
shopping them and then the freaking wind
like keeps blowing the bike sideways as
i'm going down the street oh my god
see i was going to go with the
paddleboard and then i looked at the
weather and this is like
yellow warnings it's not that bad and
then just a storm hit and i'm like
okay i get it since the wind stops i've
been waiting
okay so we have one started in the
middle here oh oh you should make four
dude everything has to be symmetrical
yeah i like it though it's very pleasing
to the eye
okay i need more stone peasants you're
all a bunch of fools
it's not even finished he's already a
dictator
poor bask in our glory there's not even
any like
subtlety to it anymore it's just poor
weak small break
me big top of egypt so how do you get
out of this
pyramid and how do you get in
that's something we figure out later you
build the trees
hello did they did they invent how to
extinguish fire first
before inventing fire i don't think so
all right i never thought of that you're
just blowing my mind right now yeah
probably the demise of humanity it's the
fact that we always invent stuff
before we figure out how to put it put
it out
yeah the safety measure comes second
yeah destroy first
rebuild second i'm a fool jump to trees
stay with the peasants oh i saw you jump
that was epic they're they're having a
pool party stop
stop go back break it up stop breaking
up back to work
build our tower yeah help build the
tower build our tower as an affront to
god
i feel like we have to take down one of
their houses it would look better it
looks better without their houses
you want to destroy the ones around the
the tower should we blow it up do
we still have that tnt oh no it's at the
base can you use it to try and kill me
what you never played two for simulator
that never happened
come on bro oh no the golem stood in the
fire what are you doing
idiot what happened he stood in the
campfire and almost died
oh my god and now he's walking away like
oh dad
i feel bad now i guess i leave
did they heal himself or i don't know it
doesn't it looks pretty cool but i think
i should double up the stairs
or triple it the excessiveness is
happening like you spent a long time
building your house yesterday
yeah you get that itch of like i have to
finish this no matter what
it doesn't matter and you put something
in one place it's like i wonder if that
look better it's like oh my god it looks
way better i have to change it all now
yeah that's what i'm doing that i feel
like has to be done bro it has to be
done bro see that looks better
oh how should we lit it we got to make
sure we lit it symmetrically as well
uh for now i'll just put stuff in the
corners oh that yeah
that's perfect one in each corner on
each level mm-hmm
yeah that's so good do you think will
smith will be in this rewind
oh he's in the new rewind just just goes
yeah
yeah it's just him reacting to him going
yeah yeah
that would actually be pretty good
that'd be yeah pretty good
self-awareness on youtube's part
maybe we should put beds in the ground
outside of it so we can just jump down
youtube is watching right now what write
that down write that down
write that down sorry what are you
saying
i was saying we should jump off the
tower into beds oh epic
oh yeah we can do that oh they're
shooting
oh they killed iron golem today yeah oh
no that means i can grab his iron that
probably means we should sleep
sleep sleep i'm good to make it i have
to make it
what happened to this house we still
have to figure out how to get in
that's tomorrow's problem tomorrow's
problem for tomorrow's
sean and felix today is just big brain
ideas yeah
we invent before we figure out the
countermeasure exactly
to air is human and also arrogance and
all other bad traits
do you think a dog has ego no just human
i just realized
this is gonna sound very big brain the
more we build
the more we need that's very big brain
thanks bro where are you you must have
so much to
stop but yeah the more we build every
layer requires
the however number of mass of block more
yeah could i have some because i don't
have any
thank you i worked hard for this all
right all right i respect it
just let me just i want you to know i
respect it did you say boom
oh do we not have enough
i don't i'm beginning to regret it now
dude we should put a campfire in the
middle
and smoke will come out of there it
looks so good how did we make a campfire
i keep forgetting you need like
there's one on the ground just steal
that one yeah but it becomes charcoal
when you take it oh you need cam stacks
you need a flint in the middle
so oh it's just coal oh coal oh cool
it's even easier to the mines
there's cold right there next to it to
the left a rock wall with tons of coal
in it
oh my god i can just jump to this area
up here now and jump to tree
break my ankles stop the morning
jack i always die in this game okay so
if i put the campfire here
no i just love how this thing is in
every shot of anything i'm doing
gigantic it's beautiful we should name
it
tuber tower two bird tower
wait does the smoke actually come out i
don't know is it
i can't see the top from down here no
oh it is that's so cute a little poof
why is there a hole here oh more poofies
cuz you dug oh lot of poofy oh yeah look
at this jack
oh that's awesome smoking kills felix
kills the youtuber that's what i
want just don't jump down in the hole
don't jump down one hole oh yeah will
you die if you've done that wait what if
we uh
ah smoke signals oh
yes that's awesome
okay gamers minecraft is the best
this game check out part 4 next time
bye gamers bye gamers remember pyramid
remember pyramid think of it when you
sleep at night the power of the pyramid
what you haven't tried tuber simulator
seriously
after 50 million outros my hatch
maya i can't damn it maya
come here don't just go it's still
relevant
just download it